- It seemed
that nothing could touch New
York governor Andrew Cuomo
after helping the state battle back
against its high COVID 19 infection rates.
He even wrote a book about it
but then governor Cuomo had
to face allegations related
to two separate scandals.
Each of which might have been
enough to topple a governor
who wasn't receiving such
a stellar approval ratings.
At this point, multiple
people have come forward
accusing governor Cuomo of multiple acts
of sexual harassment, and
many are accusing the governor
of having perpetrated
a policy that has led
to the deaths of thousands
of nursing home residents.
What are these allegations
and is governor Cuomo
in legal hot water.
(upbeat music)
Sponsored by ting mobile.
So the first scandal plaguing Andrew Cuomo
involves sexual harassment.
So far seven women have
accused the governor
of sexual harassment of various kinds.
And in response, Cuomo has dished
out the sexual harassment
defense combo played it
heaping tablespoon,
invited, and do it aside
of cancel culture and an extra helping of
"I know now the times have changed
"and these interactions
are no longer appropriate."
- I understand that
sensitivities have changed
and behavior has changed and I get it.
And I'm gonna learn from it.
- Governor, it's 2021, sexual
harassment has been an issue
for a very long time.
And you're claiming
that you didn't realize
that times have changed until this year.
That in and of itself is a
problem, especially because less
than two years ago, Cuomo
criticized the legal standard
for sexual harassment in
a highly informed way.
- The current law says sexual harassment
has to be severe or pervasive.
Severe or pervasive.
Look at those words, it has
to be severe to break the law.
It has to be pervasive.
And when you look at the
case law on that threshold
you have some despicable acts
that have been performed repeatedly,
where the court has determined.
They're not severe enough, or
they're not pervasive enough.
"They are only sporadic".The court said.
And sporadic is not pervasive.
Oh, so I can sporadically
sexually harass someone as long
as I don't go so far as
it becomes pervasive.
- So it sounds like governor
Cuomo was very familiar
with modern sexual harassment law.
But since he's now very curious
about the state of the law
what is the legal standard
for sexual harassment?
And what is the distinction
between acts that are sporadic
and behavior that is legally pervasive?
Well, we start with the
definition of sexual harassment.
Sexual harassment is a form
of sex discrimination
that violates title seven
of the civil rights act of 1964.
We generally use the
term sexual harassment to
describe a wide range of
workplace conduct, but
for sexual harassment to
actually be actionable in court
it must satisfy a legal standard.
Sexual harassment can consist
of unwanted sexual advances
or other unwelcome
conduct that is motivated
by the victim's gender.
This conduct can result in
a tangible personal action
like a demotion, or is
so severe or pervasive
as to alter the terms and
conditions of employment.
Now who can be a victim
of sexual discrimination.
Really anyone the perpetrator may be
of the same or opposite sex
or maybe a supervisor or a
coworker, or even a non-employee.
And when the harasser is the
boss courts can generally
perceive the situation to be more severe.
Now, there are generally two
kinds of sexual harassment.
The first type is often referred
to as quid pro quo, harassment
quid pro quo harassment
occurs when a person
most often the supervisor
asks an employee to
perform some sort of sexual favor
in exchange for benefits
like a raise or promotion.
And this is also a threat
scenario where a supervisor
pressures a subordinate to
do something that they want
or suffer an adverse
consequence like termination
or provide some benefit
for taking the action
that they wouldn't otherwise take.
Now, the second type
of sexual harassment is called
a hostile work environment.
And a hostile work environment is one
in which "discriminatory
intimidation, ridicule
and insult is sufficiently
severe or pervasive
as to alter the conditions
of a victim's employment."
So let's talk about that severe
and pervasive standard in
Harris V. Forklift systems.
The Supreme court said that determining
whether a workplace is sufficiently toxic
"is not, and by its nature cannot
"be a mathematically precise test."
And the court set forth
a number of factors
that courts have to
consider when evaluating
whether conduct is severe
and pervasive enough
to create a hostile work environment
such as how frequent is
the discriminatory conduct.
How severe is it?
Is it physically threatening?
Is the conduct humiliating?
Does the behavior interfere
with an employee's work performance?
Is the employee complaining
of isolated comments?
And this isn't a mathematical test.
There is a true controversy
over the ways courts
apply title seven severe
and pervasive standard.
- Oh. So I can sporadically
sexually harass someone as long
as I don't go so far as
it becomes pervasive.
- Well, yeah, that is possible.
So let's talk about
the allegations against
governor Cuomo himself.
Cuomo had a lot to say about how the legal
standard hurts sexual harassment victims
but what do the women who worked
for Cuomo have to say about
his particular conduct?
Charlotte Bennett, a
25 year old former aid
to the governor said he
hit on her several times.
He asked her questions, including
whether she had,
"Ever been with an older man?"
and whether she was monogamous
in her relationships
Cuomo knew Bennett had been
the victim of sexual abuse
and once asked her if she,
"Had trouble enjoying being with someone
"because of her trauma."
Cuomo didn't dispute Bennet's
allegations explaining instead
that he had never
intended to offend anyone.
"At work sometimes I
think I am being playful
"and make jokes that I think are funny."
"I do on occasion, tease people
"in what I think is a good natured way."
But let's use some common sense.
If the boss asked
somebody how their history
of abuse impacts their sex life
does that really truly fit the,
"It was just a joke defense."
It depends on how a jury
would these circumstances
but it doesn't seem like
a jokey conversation.
Or at least not one
that should be tolerated
in this day and age.
Now the Supreme court's severe
and pervasive standard was meant to,
"Filter out complaints attacking
"the ordinary tribulations
of the workplace
"such as the sporadic
use of abuse of language
"gender related jokes,
and occasional teasing."
A few straight remarks often
may make work uncomfortable
but they don't automatically make the work
environment hostile in the legal sense.
But the other allegations
against Cuomo go even further.
Other victims say that
Cuomo was not just a talker.
He was also a toucher.
An anonymous former aide says
that Cuomo groped her Cuomo
allegedly called the woman
to the governor's mansion under the guise
of needing help with his cell phone.
According to a police report,
"They were alone in
Cuomo's private residence
"on the second floor of the mansion
"When he closed the door
and allegedly reached
"under her blouse and
began to fondle her."
The woman came forward
after the people noticed
that she was crying
while watching Cuomo
deny other allegations
of sexual harassment against him.
Another former Cuomo
aid Lindsey Boylan said
that Cuomo once kissed
her without her consent
and suggested they play strip poker.
Boylan says that Cuomo told
her he had a crush on her
and started calling her by
the name of his ex-girlfriend.
And apparently his actions
may have escalated over.
- I am embarrassed by it.
- Another woman allegedly
had the same experience
as Boylan.
Another former Cuomo staffer analysts
told the wall street journal
that Cuomo started out
by asking her about her love life
and calling her sweetheart
which escalated to touching
her back, kissing her hand.
Eventually he called her Sparky, Blondie
sweetheart and honey.
Now, when you combine unwanted touching
and unwanted advances and
comments, you're probably
in the ballpark of a
legally actionable claim
for a hostile work
environment under title seven.
Now, presumably Cuomo will still claim
that these were allegations
from different people
at different times, and no
one filed a formal complaint
against him and all of these
things even taken together
don't rise to the severe
and pervasive standard
to make a hostile work environment claim
under sexual harassment law.
And some of these things are in fact
valid defenses under title seven,
but perhaps not all of it.
Which takes us to the
New York Human Rights Act
because title seven is a federal law
and it's not the only law that's at issue
when you're talking
about sexual harassment.
What about New York law in
what may be a delicious irony.
Andrew Cuomo is actually responsible
for changing the way
that New York interprets
the severe and pervasive standard,
which should actually make it easier
for his potential victims to sue.
New York was actually one of
the first states to decide
that the severe and
pervasive standard let too
many people get away with
offensive workplace behavior.
Previously New York state
law, mirrored title seven
and required an employee to show
that the alleged harassment
was severe and pervasive
in order to say an actionable
claim against an employer.
But in 2019 New York
amended its human rights
act to eliminate the severe
and pervasive standard
entirely under the act.
And employee only has to show
that the alleged harassment or rises
above the level of petty slights
and trivial inconveniences.
The new law also removes
one of the key defenses used
by employers that the employee never used.
The employer's internal
complaint procedure.
There's also a new three
year statute of limitations.
So if Cuomo did indeed harass anyone
over the last three years
they have a clear path to
Sue under New York law.
So congratulations,
governor, you played yourself
you did the right thing
and immediately follow
that up potentially allegedly
by doing the wrong thing.
Now, what this means for his
political career is uncertain.
New York attorney general Letitia James
has appointed an independent
investigator to look
into these claims.
And many of the prominent
Democrats and Republicans
in New York have called
on the governor to resign.
The governor has often dismissed
this as cancel culture.
But if indeed these allegations are true
this isn't cancellation,
it's just consequences.
Which takes us to the second scandal
that Cuomo is facing related
to nursing homes and COVID patients.
Cuomo second scandals
started with a dispute
over how the state of New
York handled COVID patients
in nursing homes between March
25th and May 10th in 2020.
Early in the pandemic on March 25th
Cuomo state health
department ordered nursing
homes to accept recovering COVID
19 patients from hospitals.
The directive said that
if a nursing home resident
had been hospitalized
and was stable enough to be discharged
the nursing facility
needed to readmit them.
Cuomo rescinded the order on May 10th
but what's the problem here?
Well, on March 23rd, just
before Cuomo's March 25th order
the federal government issued guidance
on how to handle COVID 19 in nursing homes
not surprisingly the
guidance boil down to this
a patient must be medically ready
for discharge to a
long-term care facility.
And the facility must be capable
of caring for patients
recovering from COVID 19.
If either of those
conditions could not be met
the facilities should not admit the person
because they could spread COVID-19
throughout the entire nursing home.
Now, the first area of
dispute here is whether
the state department of
health order conflicted with
the federal government's guidance.
Cuomo says it did not.
The New York health
department's order requires a doctor
to confirm a resident is
medically stable for a return.
The order also says staff must conform
to new York's requirements
on environmental cleaning and PPE.
On the other hand, it
clearly urges nursing
homes to readmit COVID 19 patients,
"No resident shall be denied
readmission or admission
"to the NH nursing home
solely based on a confirmed
"or suspected diagnosis of COVID-19."
NHs are prohibited
from requiring a hospitalized
resident who is determined
medically stable to be tested
for COVID-19 prior to
admission or readmission.
That's pretty strong language.
And it precluded nursing
homes from doing testing
as a basis for denying
a patient readmission.
New York's logic was
that removing recovering
patients would free
up hospital capacity
which was thought to
be in dwindling supply.
And at one point was at
almost full capacity.
However, we now know
that this could have
been a dangerous move.
Recovering patients still shed the virus
creating a strong possibility
that they could infect other people
in the nursing homes if they
were not properly quarantine.
And the people in nursing homes tend to be
over the age of 70, the
very age group that is most
at risk of death from COVID-19.
Cuomo claims that he followed
the Trump administration's
guidelines on nursing homes.
But after the March 25th order,
there was immediate pushback
by various advocacy groups
who felt that Cuomo was
mandating the nursing homes
admit COVID 19 positive people
regardless of whether they
could meet safety standards.
Cuomo himself, publicly
pressured facilities
to find space for COVID patients.
- They don't have the right to object.
- He said on April 23rd.
And yet Cuomo's further comments
on that day actually did
track the federal guidelines.
- So if you can't provide adequate care
you can't have the patient
in your facility and that's
your basic fiduciary obligation.
I would say ethical obligation.
And it's also your legal obligation.
If you can't provide adequate care
the person must be transferred.
If you have COVID people,
they have to be quarantined.
They have to have separate staff.
That's the rule.
If you can't do it
we'll put them in a
facility that can do it.
That's the rule
- That's the underlying
issue, but there's also
an undercounting and
potential under-reporting
issue regarding the data
related to nursing home deaths.
Now the second scandal
also involved how the state
calculated and reported
nursing home deaths.
In particular when a nursing home resident
who contracted COVID 19 died
after being transported to
a hospital for treatment.
The person wasn't included as,
"Nursing home death."
In New York, this wasn't
immediately apparent
from the numbers and
explanation the state officials
were releasing to the press.
Eventually by May though
the state confirmed
that it did not include
these deaths in its count.
And while the legislature
and media were asking
about the correct numbers
Cuomo was enjoying great
national popularity
for his televised COVID-19 briefings
and promoting his book American
crisis leadership lessons
from the COVID-19 pandemic.
And Cuomo was well on his way
to America's governor status.
Just like Rudy Giuliani
had once been considered America's mayor.
And like Rudy Cuomo had
high approval ratings
that led many to speculate
that he would one day become president.
And what happened next?
Well, as Rudy knows pride
go with before the fall.
By fall Trump's justice
department was on the case.
And assistant AG sent Cuomo
a request for complete data
on all public and private
nursing home facilities.
Cuomo claimed he was being harassed
by the Trump administration
but it wasn't just the
Trump justice department.
A patient advocacy group
did a foyer request
for nursing home data.
And of course he was still tangling
with the legislature over the numbers.
And at the same time, Cuomo
tried to Stonewall everyone.
But in January Cuomo's
own attorney general
Letitia James issued a
scathing report on the matter,
"This preliminary for the 62 facilities.
"And the time periods noted above suggest
"the COVID-19 resident deaths associated
"with nursing homes in New
York state appear to be
"under counted by DOH
by approximately 50%."
The health department
quickly revised the death
report showing an additional 3,829 deaths
of nursing home residents.
Governor Cuomo and
Michigan governor Whitmer
issued a joint statement complaining
that they were facing scrutiny
from a Trump administration.
That was hell bent on revenge.
The former president apparently hated both
of these public officials
who clashed with him often.
But here's the thing,
"You can't complain that
there's a political witch hunt
"if you actually did something wrong."
And it's probably fair
to say that it should not
have taken nine months for
the state to be upfront
about these particular numbers.
Based on the facts that we have now,
it looks like not all of Cuomo's
actions were on the level.
But the question is
did governor Cuomo violate any law?
Obviously governors receive
wide latitude in terms
of the policy decisions
that they have to make.
Well, when the Trump justice
department sought data
on the nursing home
matters, it's cited as power
under the civil rights of
institutionalized persons act.
The CRIPA authorizes
the U S attorney general
to investigate conditions of confinement
at state and local government institutions
such as prisons, jail,
juvenile correction facilities
and publicly operated nursing homes.
Now CRIPA only applies
to public facilities
which only account for about 5%
of the state's nursing homes.
But the attorney general
can investigate widespread
deficiencies that seriously
jeopardize the health
and safety of public
nursing home residents.
However, the government
does not have authority
under CRIPA to investigate
isolated incidents
or to represent individuals.
For the attorney general to sue.
There has to be a
reasonable cause to believe
that the nursing home conditions
are egregious or flagrant
that they are subjecting residents to,
"Grievous harm."
And that they are part of a,
"Pattern or practice of resistance
"to a resident's constitutional
or federal rights."
So the CRIPA covers things
like a pattern of sexual abuse, neglect
unmet mental health needs,
or inadequate education
and facilities that host children.
Was the situation
in new York's public
nursing homes, abusive
or grossly neglectful?
That has yet to be determined.
But in July New York health
authorities presented data
allegedly showing that the Corona virus
had infected nursing homes far earlier
than once believed.
In that,
"Readmitting residents
that had been hospitalized
"for coronavirus did not contribute
"to a higher fatality
rate in those facilities."
But that's just one opinion given
by Cuomo's own health authorities
during the same month that
he signed his book deal.
The report compiled by attorney general
James saw things differently.
James found,
"Lack of compliance with
infection control protocols
"insufficient personal
protective equipment PPE
"for nursing home staff
insufficient COVID-19 testing
"for residents and staff
in the early stages
"of the pandemic and the
state reimbursement model
"for nursing homes that gave,
"Financial incentive to owners
"of for-profit nursing
homes to transfer funds
"to related parties
"ultimately increasing their
own profit instead of investing
"in higher levels of staffing and PPE."
Cuomo claims that other States issued
similar nursing home directives
and are not being investigated.
However, once again, that
doesn't tell us anything
about whether what New York did would be
considered widespread abuse
or neglect under the law.
Although Cuomo hasn't resigned,
he has lost the support
of the democratic party in the state
which controls both houses
of the state government.
And the Senate judiciary
committee has opened
an impeachment inquiry.
Now that's a lot of scandals
for one governor and
it's only been possible
because whistleblowers have come forward.
And if you have personal
information that Andrew Cuomo
may have broken the law,
you should call authorities.
And the best way to make that
call is with ting mobile.
It's good to see that
the segues are still dark
even in 2020.
But ting mobile is actually great.
I personally switched to ting mobile.
Why? because of this.
Yes, that is a real cell
phone bill that I got
with my previous provider.
And it's why I personally
switched to ting.
And ting mobile has three
brand new plans to make sure
that never happens again.
You can get talking texts
for only $10 a month data plan starting
at $25 a month and
unlimited for $45 a month.
Switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great too
because ting partners with
several massive networks
probably the very same one
that you're using right now
but at a huge discount.
Now, actually, I can't tell you which ones
because I always respect contracts
but let's just say my service
hasn't changed at all.
Now I had been on the phone
with my previous provider for
hours for the simplest things
because I was always on hold.
But with ting, you can call
them up and immediately talk
to a real human being
or you can talk to them
on chat, internet discord, you
name it, they are available.
And it's incredibly easy to
transfer service sustained
by just simply ordering a ting SIM card
popping it in and setting it up.
No phone calls required.
It's like magic.
And if you're around wifi all the time
like you're working from home
you have the flexibility to
save hundreds of dollars a year.
And ting still gives you
the option to just pay
for what you use with their flex plan.
It's a smarter, cheaper version
of the same plan that they've always had.
And now they just give you the possibility
of unlimited versions as well.
So if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
So if you go to legal eagle.ting.com
or click on the link in the description
you can use your last
bill to compare just how
much you would save.
And legal Eagles will
also get a $25 credit
that could cover two months of service.
So just click on the link
in the description and give it a try.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my
analysis, leave your objections
in the comments and
check out this playlist
over here with all my
other real law reviews
where I talk about all the
crazy stuff that's happening
in the legal world.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.